[Applause]
the chants are loud and unforgiving
go home gota return our stolen money
we want our future back
people are struggling to afford food
medicine cooking gas and fuel as sri
lanka faces its worst economic crisis
since independence in 1948.
it's mainly
for children it's milk powder
and for even adults are affected with
the lack of milk powder
so many things arise
everything has gone up
many people blame the rajapaksa family
for the crisis from heroes who oversaw
the military victory over the tamil
tigers in 2009 family members have now
become a target of anger and ridicule
what is very
unfortunate
is the sense of entitlement that they
have
that they
are meant to rule this country
almost like a royal family
and that sense i think comes from the
fact that
they were in charge when the 30-year war
came to an end
and they feel that they are the saviors
of the country pereira and other
analysts say the rajabaksa government
took out big loans for giant
infrastructure projects after the
country's civil war ended and cut taxes
the president has admitted failure
anti-corruption activists also allege
billions of dollars may have been made
from illegal deals in recent years
we lost so many cases we have more than
500 files
all the in the court but nothing
happened
some cases are hearing it's not
ending some cases are going but
some came back by the bribery commission
ocid because evidence not enough and
some technical matters the raj boxes
changed the constitution twice
critics say this allowed them to contest
an unlimited number of terms in the
presidential office
weaken parliamentary oversight and
remove checks and balances against the
politicization of public services and
the police
the unprecedented protests in recent
weeks has worried the ruling family
president gotab rajapaksa has brought in
a new prime minister and a new cabinet
but despite the demonstrations the
rajapaksas still control a majority in
parliament and the president is refusing
protesters calls to step down mina
fernandez al-jazeera colombo